et quand même dit yellow ce président
des républicaines sauver hre 6 france
bonsoir monsieur merci d'être avec nous
démocrates et républicains vont t'ils
s'accorder selon vous
je crois pas dans un premier temps jeu
steam qui est ce qu'ils vont faire et je
ne sais pas si ça a été bien unique et
il ya aussi les questions de faire voter
un plan provisoire et temporaire pour le
prochain deux mois parce que pour éviter
le shodan au lard et des du gouvernement
fédéral ils peuvent envisager un budget
pendant deux mois jusqu'au 2 décembre
ce conte dont il ya un blocage important
et au sein de la parti républicain
concernant le plafond d'endettement qui
aujourd'hui aucun des républicains est
d'accord pour accorder ce sera un chèque
en blanc donné administration bail dès
qu'on estime et responsables continuent
d des dépenses colossales qui ont encore
par leur administration et que on estime
qu'ils aient leur administration étant
irresponsable par rapport à l'amérique
et les conséquences que ça aura sur
l'économie américaine il faut savoir qui
et on n'a pas parlé dans votre reportage
qui est ça comporte une partie aussi à
des mesures fiscales les plus
importantes depuis plusieurs décennies
et qui les familles les plus modestes
vont être imposées dans le cadre de ce
plan des 5 milliards dé dollars et ils
vont le faire payer halle aux américains
selon des mesures fiscales selon des
impositions records qu'on n'a jamais vue
aux états unis et aujourd'hui quand vous
entendez manar pelosi et des autres
démocrates parler de ce projet il va
coûter 0 parce que qu'ils vont aller
chez les américains font leur faire
payer ces maisons là et aujourd'hui les
républicains appellent cela démocratie
mais la responsabilité des dés leur
mesure et on leur demander s'ils
souhaitent procéder à ces déplacements
tu es l'endettement qu'elle assume tout
seul et comme bruit vous couper vers
cette force à nous acteurs pour
compléter ce reportage qui est un
reportage factuel vous êtes là pour
apporter votre opinion de dominique
d'ailleurs
ça veut dire quoi concrètement selon
vous il n'ya pas de ce n'est pas un
budget sincère comme on dirait en france
il n'est pas assez franc il n'assume pas
c'est ça que vous reprochez au
jeu aujourd'hui pour vous donner un
petit exemple la projets verts des
démocrates qu'est ce qui s'est passé aux
états unis on a fait subir aux familles
les plus modestes d d d augmentation des
prix des gaz et d'énergie qu'on n'a
jamais vus depuis deux décennies avec
leurs formes qui proposent ces prix vont
augmenter
aujourd'hui aussi toute la politique ils
ont arrêté l'exploitation des gaz aux
etats-unis et on voit les prix des gaz
augmente et du pétrole de tout ce qui
est l'énergie augmente aux états unis et
il est choisi à adopter je vous explique
non parce que les maisons qu'ils ont met
en place qui est un parti une volée à
environnemental très important par
rapport à ce qu'ils sont en train de
faire et ça à cette partie là aussi ça
reproduit le même projet vert qui a été
mis en place en allemagne et qui était
un échec ces dernières cinq à huit ans
et ils vont répéter la même chose et on
va faire face à une situation très
problématique aux états unis qu'on va
dépendre des voitures électriques qui
toutes les sources d'énergie qu'on
n'achète que ce soit des gaz du pétrole
est aussi tout ce qui est des tiers mais
tous des sources pour les voitures
électriques d'où ça vient de l'étranger
et surtout de la chine on va créer une
dépendance à sur la chine qui va être
renforcée par cette politique qui sera
mis en place et aujourd'hui on doit dire
à un moment donné stop et a aujourd'hui
il y à cet encouragement de la part des
démocrates de vouloir aller sans
réfléchir je considère que nous de notre
côté qui les défendent volé à qu'ils ont
mis en place sont excessives
et on a essayé de négocier au sein des
décombres républicain un budget beaucoup
plus modeste beaucoup plus tempérée par
rapport aux différents objectifs qui ont
été prévues pour aider l'économie on ne
se rend pas compte que les milliers des
milliards qui ont été dépensés et qui
aujourd'hui on voit bien entendu des
effets des situations on voit une
inflation massive aux etats-unis du
jamais vu depuis à deux décennies donc
c'est ce qui va se passer aux états unis
joe biden est évidemment aussi vivement
critiqué pour certains de ses choix en
politique étrangère notamment le retrait
précipité d'afghanistan en tout cas la
manière de retirer ses troupes il est
justement en train de payer ses choix en
matière de politique étrangère également
ça n'a rien à voir selon vous
moi je considère ip les prix il paie un
prix important parce que c'est sa
politique domestique est un public
international sont tous les deux liés
par exemple aujourd'hui il essaie de
faire passer une politique verte mais on
accords dont on nous quittons
l'afghanistan ce qui est connu comme
l'arabie saoudite du lithium il a passé
toutes les ressources du huitième à la
chine il a ouvert cette mine cette
réserve mondiale du 8e qu'il va nous
serons plus dépendants de la chine et
qui aujourd'hui qu'il autre côté il veut
dire aux américains on va vers une
économie verte dépendant des voitures
électriques et qui dispose d d d
monopole de toutes les matières
premières aujourd'hui c'est la chine et
envers des données les deuxièmes
réserves du monde aux orres au régime à
chinois et il doit faire face à cette
situation comment ça s'explique comment
on peut expliquer aux américains qui on
va créer de plus en plus de dépendance
sur des pays étrangers surtout non sur
un pays qu'on concède hostiles aux
intérêts mag comme la chine est
aujourd'hui les américains font de moins
en moins confiance à messieurs byden ses
choix
son indifférence vis-à-vis des
américains et il doit aussi s'expliquer
sur sa politique fiscale qui va mettre
en place parce qu'aujourd'hui on va se
rendre compte que les américains avec
l'inflation est tout coûte plus cher des
niveaux que ce soit l'alimentation
le début de votre intervention ces deux
mesures fiscales vont subir selon
vous merci à nos appels vous êtes
président des républicains soit vers 6
france merci à vous et avocats comme
américain merci bien